這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
美國和俄羅斯聯手
在最後關頭削弱了聯合國的殺手機器人安全文件
原本的安全文字
被刪成內容大幅弱化的版本
說起來很諷刺
美國和俄羅斯在烏克蘭戰爭中分屬對立陣營
可是一到日內瓦談判桌，卻站到同一邊
反對更具體、有約束力的國際規則
美俄擋下的，到底是什麼規則？
是致命自主武器，英文縮寫LAWS
能在操作員不介入時
自行選擇並攻擊目標
所以關鍵在於：機器已經找到目標、
排好順序時，人類還有沒有最後決定權
這可不是紙上談兵
《華盛頓郵報》報導
Palantir的Maven整合Anthropic的Claude
為美軍即時選目標與排序提供支援
2月28日展開的史詩怒火行動
首24小時攻擊超過1000個伊朗目標
平均每86秒一個
就在同一天
伊朗米納卜1所小學遭到攻擊
至少165人死亡，很多是孩童
美方初步調查指向過時的目標資料
這些資料在加速的目標鏈裡
一路通過了人類簽核
所以，有人簽核，不代表複核就有效
照理說，這正是國際規則該管的事
可是在《特定常規武器公約》底下
各國從2014年開始談，談了10多年
到現在還沒有專門針對致命自主武器、
具有法律約束力的國際規則
為什麼會卡這麼久？
其實想開談的國家是多數
共有76國支持以這份文本為基礎開談
但制度採共識決，只要1國反對就卡住
文件只能一直退讓
最後那一步退讓，發生在9月4日
主席宣布停表
聯合國的公開鏡頭幾乎到此為止
《華盛頓郵報》報導
美國和俄羅斯閉門約15小時逐條改稿
到9月5日凌晨才達成共識
那15個小時刪掉了什麼？
《華盛頓郵報》的獨家調查指出
其中一條是：AI產生的目標
在攻擊前必須由人類複核
這一條，被刪了
被拿掉的還不只這一條
6月5日的公開文本，還寫著倫理考量
武器系統也應該可預測、可靠、可追溯、可解釋
人權觀察組織指出
這些字眼在最後報告裡全被移除
並直接點名美國和俄羅斯
一路刪下來，9月由128個締約方接受的
只剩1份沒有法律約束力的元素文件
這份文件不是條約
也不代表各國同意開始談條約
美國國內也在拉扯
Anthropic執行長Dario
Amodei替Claude畫了2條紅線：
不做大規模國內監控、不做全自主武器
國防部長Pete
Hegseth卻把這家公司列為供應鏈風險
這場衝突鬧上了法院
8月
加州聯邦法官裁定政府以較廣泛措施懲罰Anthropic違法
可是9月25日
華府聯邦上訴法院在另案又以2比1
支持五角大廈依另一部供應鏈法排除Anthropic
目前沒有誰全勝
法院沒有定論，國際規則也還沒定
11月16日到20日，各國會再回日內瓦
決定要展開有約束力的議定書談判
還是繼續討論
真正要問的是，人類還來不來得及
把最後一道有效複核寫進國際規則